listen
on our way here we had a conversation in
the car okay
um
cause we were reviewing another video
where it was a video about a man in a
wheelchair uh getting shot eight times
by the couch right by the cops
and then i saw i just said oh [ __ ] the
cops involved who got shot and he said a
guy in a wheelchair and i said oh [ __ ]
they see me rolling
they hated
oh wait a minute remix they see me roll
and it's pretty [ __ ] brutal but
comedy [ __ ] ruin me because i'll find
anything funny in anything yeah i
realize that i don't have the same
sensibilities of other people when it
comes to like
comedic stuff or anything like that it
can be really [ __ ] up and if it's done
creatively enough i can't help but laugh
yes it's like even racist comments yes
even racist comments like i've been
laughing sometimes so i'm like
i'm like wow i never i never heard that
one before
and i'm gonna be like
that was pretty creative yeah you you
went the creative route yeah good job
good on you yeah yeah
that's why i find once you start doing
comedy it's very hard to have friends
outside of the comedy yes you're fine
yes you can really be real
you can still maintain friendships
because then you see some of my favorite
people to talk to because i'm like
i could say anything to you guys you're
not going to be like yo like you you
know if i say something stupid but like
you won't be like oh did you hear what
yeah oh my god well that was a line
you know like there was a time oh you go
ahead yeah but you know that's an
interesting thing that that whole thing
because
i don't know if you're also like this
i'm pretty protective of the title
comedian in that if you're not really a
comedian and you try to use that veil
like i don't give you the benefit of
that yeah when i go to an open mic for
example i will listen to some people do
like straight up just racism on stage
yes okay
and if i don't think that they're even
attempting a joke i look at them funny
yeah if i see you or at least attempting
humor okay then i'm like you know what
maybe i should yeah but what's the
difference the process i guess the
process i think there's nuance it's not
easy it's not always a clear line so
sometimes people are like well how do
you determine i'm like listen i'm not
going to be honest with you i can't say
100 yeah i can't say 100 but generally
comics are pretty good
about giving people the benefit right
because we try really tough stuff that
sometimes really doesn't land or is
really edgy and divides people
completely yeah right so
um i think i give people that chance and
then even if i don't like the joke if i
see that there was an attempt then i'm
like whatever i don't really care
also this is gonna sound [ __ ] up i'm
not against racist jokes
i'm not either
you know i mean like even if i think a
joke is hacky yeah and i don't really
rock with it
i'm fine with people being able to do
them
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
definitely and
yeah i think like that's the
conversation coming up a lot lately
because you know sometimes you'll you'll
see people who are like political
commentators and they'll be like oh you
know it's just comedy and i'm like
i'll give you the benefit of the doubt
sure but i don't record the same benefit
to you that i would have stand up
comedian in a comedian context you guys
you guys get what i'm talking about am i
like yeah you know i don't think you're
crazy the context is really something
telling like if it's not if it was the
context of a comment i'm gonna be like
okay the point is to get laughs or uh
get laughed with discomfort or whatever
whatnot you're supposed to get laughs
right i get that yeah
if it's not that or there was no like
i'm not
it's not so much if the joke is funny or
not it's really if
there was
a process in which we're trying to do if
there was a way you were going with the
joke if that i could see which we're
going if i'm just like there was no
premise there was there was no elements
of comedy right there was no punch there
was no premise you just said some racist
[ __ ] yeah
that's not comedy yeah
it's saying some racist [ __ ]
so
yeah where's the line i think it's just
it's a case-by-case basis exactly you
know like yeah cool and if you can't try
stuff
that's
i for lack of a better term edgy it's
hard to get to that level where you can
construct a really good joke you know
what comes to mind very it ties into the
last thing stabbing someone with a fork
because of an overcooked thing
schultz has a really really really good
joke i [ __ ] find it hilarious and i'm
sure this was tough to
uh to work on and do yeah but
essentially the premise is like
ethnic food is so good because like
there's no women's rights you know it's
like
so like you know like that you know once
the
when maria overcooks the lasagna you
know like tables are getting flipped and
it's like [ __ ] murray so next time
it's like oh man it's beautiful
oppression
and he talks about the you know those
premises like the cultures that are he's
like middle eastern food have you tried
that [ __ ] amazing women's rights ah you
know if you tried swedish food that [ __ ]
is garbage
i think that's super funny but i'm sure
like people really pulled back probably
yeah definitely but there is there is
is the point of that joke is not to be
sexist or racist
the point of that joke is to actually
pinpoint that
in some certain countries there is still
that going on that's how i see it you
know i mean this is it's talking about
abuse that is still going on you know
one thing i think people make a mistake
of and i think this is an issue with it
is people go to a comedy show sometimes
thinking they're going to hear some
truth
and my general experience with comedy
and comedians in general is like they
will stretch facts they will omit things
from a story they'll
exaggerate or make up details to get to
a punch line at times
right it's a hip-hop concert yeah it's
like it's like and i think folks
sometimes don't understand that it's
like sometimes people will be like well
does dave chappelle got his facts wrong
and his last special i'm like breath
this is nice it's just national
geographic
you should not and that's why
the same way i don't take it very
seriously when they get it wrong i also
don't take it too seriously when they
get it right i don't generally look like
me personally i don't look at comedians
be like the other truth sayers who you
know i'm just like ref this is just
funny and maybe there's a nugget in
that's an interesting observation right
but
i think people have to stop
deconstructing comedy and stand up as
political commentary all the time oh my
god anna gatsby had
all her facts right yeah that [ __ ] was
not funny
the point was to be funny
you missed the point you were factual
not funny yeah so
all right cool she's fine i don't know
if you can even say she was factual it's
just a perspective and you know what
there was an attempt to be funny there
so i don't even get mad at her i just i
find it cringe when people go in there
like [ __ ]
revolutionary uh you know standing up
for women's rights and i'm like stand up
con i'm like bruh
just go to the show enjoy some last
maybe there's some like controversial
stuff but if you come out of there
having your like whole political stances
changed then i think you're going at
comedy the wrong way because you're not
recognizing the comics are lying about
facts they're making up [ __ ] they're
obfuscating things that are important to
the story
but they're not journalists so it
doesn't matter they really look at
comics
like
they're like
trevor noah doing the daily show yeah or
when they look at jon stewart it's like
it's not the same thing
jon stewart on stage is not the same as
jon stewart trevor noah on stage is not
the same one as said the same thing as
trevor noah when he has he has a show
right when he has a show he uses comedy
but that's not the point of the show
exactly exactly so i think
the the the the the dissecting of comedy
specials makes me cringe a little bit
yeah because i'm like you're missing the
point of this whole event yeah it's it's
absurdity it's comedy by definition is a
matter of exaggeration it can never be
factually just truth
so i don't know that was just something
that i think really [ __ ] with people's
perception when they hear it because
they're hearing someone talking to a mic
he's lying
it's a performance it's not meant to be
the truth oh my god he's lying he's
drake
it's a performance calm down
it's the same thing as hip-hop
there's a lot of people that tell
stories and hip-hop that story was
exaggerated and when it's not
exaggerated they go to jail because
that's the evidence of a crime
how about a week ago yes
i think that's like the big problem that
folks have and i think that's why folks
are getting caught up in all this stuff
you think it's all the truth same thing
i think hip-hop went to the same thing
yeah but they're telling stories
yeah not theirs they are the stories
they made up
maybe they made it up yeah it doesn't
matter yeah
anyways it's entertainment